(Musique épique)
Arrêtez tout, vous vous trompez !
Eh oui, car toutes les pierres ne se valent pas.
Ou plutôt...
Tous les minéraux ne sont pas égaux.
Vous connaissez l'échelle de Mohs ?
C'est l'allemand Friedrich Mohs
qui l'a inventée en 1812.
Ce mec était minéralogiste et fils de...
marchand.
Il aimait bien ranger les cailloux
dans des petites boîtes.
Il a même imaginé une systématique des minéraux
en les rangeant par ordre,
classe, espèce, genre, tout ça
comme Linné l'avait fait moins d'un siècle
plus tôt sur les êtres vivants.
Je trouve ça assez cool...
story bro.
Pour pouvoir reconnaître les minéraux,
il a même développé
sa propre échelle de dureté. Et
alors qu'est ce donc que la dureté ?
Je vous vois venir bande de pervers,
c'est physique.
C'est une grandeur physique. C'est la
mesure de la résistance à la pénétration...
(Apparté) C'est de pire en pire.
A l'origine, c'était défini comme la
facilité ou la difficulté avec laquelle
on pouvait rayer un minéral. Donc plus il
est dur à rayer, plus il est dur.
Merci la science.
Plus il est facile à rayer et plus il est tendre.
Et pour pouvoir reconnaître les minéraux,
il nous faut des instruments.
Non, pas ce genre d'instruments.
Bienvenue dans le musée de la torture.
(Musique mexicaine joyeuse)
L'échelle se compose de dix
minéraux étalons.
Pas comme des chevaux fossilisés,
mais comme des minéraux de
référence, qui sont numérotés de 1 à 10.
En 1, on a le talc,
qui est le plus tendre.
Et en 10, nous avons le diamant qui est le plus dur.
Le plus dur qu'on connaisse, en tout cas.
Donc le principe, c'est que chaque minéral
raye ceux qui sont en dessous
de lui.
Si je prends ce quartz améthyste,
de dureté 7,
et ce gypse de dureté 2, eh bien
celui-là va relayer celui-ci.
Comme vous pouvez le voir ici.
La réciproque n'est pas vraie.
Le gypse ne peut pas non plus me rayer
parce que je ne suis pas un minéral.
Par contre, je peux le rayer à l'ongle.
Regardez-moi ça !
Oh bah non !
"Tu l'as cassé ?"
J'en ai perdu un petit bout.
Et ça, c'est parce que mon ongle,
votre ongle, NOTRE ONGLE
a une dureté de 2,5 à peu près.
Il peut rayer tout ce qu'il y a en-dessous
et pas au-dessus.
Donc ayez toujours un ongle sur vous,
C'est vachement pratique.
Euuuh, tchu tchu tchu...
C'est vrai je dis beaucoup tchu tchu tchu.
Il est bon le micro ?
TCHUTCHUTCHU
Tout en haut, j'en parlais,
le diamant peut uniquement
se faire rayer par un autre diamant.
Ca tombe vachement bien parce qu'on est
tous tellement riches qu'on a plusieurs
diamants chez nous, on peut
se permettre de les rayer en plus.
On peut aussi se servir d'outils.
J'ai parlé de l'ongle, mais
mais il y a aussi une pièce en cuivre,
du verre ou un couteau.
Vous l'aurez compris, ça marche par comparaison.
C'est ce qu'on appelle une échelle ordinale.
Vous avez un caillou standard,
vous essayez de trouver ce que c'est.
Vous pouvez essayer de le lécher,
comme on a vu précédemment
mais si vous tenez à la vie,
vous pouvez essayer de le rayer d'abord.
Avec votre ongle par exemple,
et si c'est votre ongle qui perd
vous savez qu'il a une dureté
supérieure à 2,5 et au fur et à mesure
vous pouvez agir par discrimination
et essayer à peu près d'identifier votre caillou.
Tchu tchu tchu
"Arrête !"
Or donc, on ne connaît pas de minéral "naturel"
qui soit plus dur que le diamant,
à l'heure actuelle.
En tout cas, il me semble.
Même si tous les six mois, des rigolos annoncent
qu'on a détrôné le diamant, GENRE LA CARMELTAZITE
en décembre 2018, mais à chaque fois
bah en fait non.
Pour la carmeltazite en particulier, je vous renvoie
vers l'excellente vidéo de Yan l'original.
Ou alors si c'est des minéraux qui sont
plus durs que le diamant, ben c'est pas
vraiment des minéraux c'est des
matériaux synthétiques
donc du coup bah si c'est pas naturel ça
compte pas, norage les chimistes.
Alors il va sans dire que l'ensemble de
l'ouvragé est une critique de la pensée
de Heidegger qui, entre nous, est un gros con.
Mais qu'est-ce que je fais là en fait ?
C'est pas pour autant qu'il n'y a que
ces duretés-là qui existent.
Y'en a plein d'autres, c'est une échelle continue.
Par exemple vous avez la moissanite
qui a une dureté de 9.5 donc elle va
carrer ses miches entre le corindon,
qu'on utilise pour le papier de verre,
et le diamant.
Mais je sais bien ce que vous brûlez
de me demander.
Alors pourquoi POURQUOI donc
tous les minéraux n'ont pas la même dureté ?
Eh ben ça, c'est une bonne question
et je suis allée la poser à un vrai pro.
C'est parti !
Bonjour Pierre Pierre, vous êtes
directeur du lobby des minéraux et
amateur d'andouillette.
Alors je vous arrête tout de suite,
ici on s'assoit sur les tables.
Voilà c'est mieux.
Nous avons enquêté, et nous avons pu
nous procurer des documents
d'une source confidentielle. Wikipédia.
Comme vous pouvez le voir ici,
ces lignes nous montrent que tous les
minéraux n'ont pas la même dureté.
Est-ce que vous confirmez ces informations ?
Comment vous justifiez ces inégalités ?
Comptez-vous faire quelque chose ?
Un silence éloquent.
En gros, ça dépend de la structure
cristalline de notre minéral.
Selon la nature des liaisons entre les atomes.
Si les liaisons sont fortes, par exemple
des liaisons covalentes, avec les atomes
qui partagent deux électrons entre eux,
on aura plus de mal à casser ces liaisons
pour faire des "microsillons", des rayures quoi.
C'est logique.
Par exemple, le quartz et le diamant
ont des structures vraiment bien rigides,
En 3D avec des liaisons covalentes,
donc c'est difficile de les casser.
Vous avez aussi un autre facteur :
c'est la taille des cristaux.
Le quartz, par exemple, fait des gros cristaux
bien formés. Mastoc.
En échange, l'argile, qui est aussi un minéral
mais pour le coup, il est
constitué de plein de petits cristaux
microscopiques qui vont s'agréger.
Là, pour le coup, c'est beaucoup plus facile
de se frayer un chemin entre les
cristaux. C'est comme si vous essayiez de
graver votre nom dans la neige ou dans
du sable avec votre index,
c'est beaucoup plus facile que de
le faire sur un mur de béton par exemple.
Mais comme bien souvent,
cette échelle de Mohs a aussi ses limites.
La première limite c'est que les
minéraux sont une fabrication artisanale
c'est pas industriel donc la composition
va varier très légèrement d'un minéral à
l'autre pour une même espèce. Et ça peut
engendrer des duretés qui varient légèrement.
Et si notre minéral est un peu érodé
en surface ou oxydé au contact de l'air,
ça aussi ça peut influre sur sa dureté.
Influre ?J'ai dit influre ? Bon ben influre.
Pour rester dans l'esprit musée de la torture,
on conseille de casser votre minéral
pour avoir une surface bien neuve,
bien fraîche, avant de le rayer.
Mais surtout ce que je trouve hyper intéressant,
c'est que certains minéraux
ont une dureté variable selon la
direction dans laquelle on les raye.
On dit qu'ils sont anisotropes, ça veut dire
qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes
propriétés physiques dans
toutes les directions de l'espace.
Je trouve ça vraiment hyper classe.
Un exemple frappant, c'est celui du disthène
qui a une dureté de 8 dans un sens
et de 4 dans l'autre.
Ça dépend de la nature des liaisons
qui lient les atomes entre eux. Dans
un sens, il défonce sa mère le quartz
et dans l'autre, un simple coup d'apatite
est paf, il est en PLS.
La dernière critique, c'est que l'échelle
n'est pas linéaire, donc la dureté entre
les premiers minéraux de l'échelle est
plus proche que la dureté des derniers
minéraux de l'échelle.
Vous voyez sur ce graphe,
Le diamant n'est même plus dedans !
C'est un peu pas top pour
une échelle de référence.
Pour moderniser (elle prononce mal le mot)
(elle se marre)
Pour moderniser cette échelle,
des scientifiques ont proposé des
alternatives.
On a d'autres échelles de dureté.
En général, c'est des mesures qui sont
effectuées en pressant le minéral avec
une pointe ou une bille,
qui peut être en acier ou en diamant.
Et donc à partir de la réponse du minéral,
on arrive à en déduire sa dureté.
Il y a aussi d'autres paramètres physiques
qu'on peut mesurer,
comme le module de compressibilité
ou le module de cisaillement
mais je vais pas entrer dans les détails
parce que la vie est bien trop courte.
Bref, c'est quand même vachement
pratique notre échelle de Mohs
parce que ça nous permet
d'aller sur le terrain
avec notre ongle et notre couteau
et comme ça on peut identifier
les minéraux qui croisent notre
chemin.
C'est pour ça qu'elle est
encore aujourd'hui beaucoup utilisée,
à la fois sur le terrain et enseignée
sur les bancs de la fac.
Et c'est justement pour cette raison
que j'ai fait cette vidéo.
Oui car aujourd'hui, j'ai besoin de vous !
(Musique émotion)
Ta grosse concierge folle d'amour ose
quémander tes caresses divines.
C'est avec cette phrase que les
étudiants apprennent l'échelle de Mohs
depuis des milliards d'années.
Moi-même, c'est comme ça que je l'ai apprise.
Je sais pas ce que vous en pensez,
je trouve ça absolument révoltant.
De quel droit ils nous tutoient ?!?
Si vous aussi cette phrase vous outre,
agissez.
C'est le moment de signer ma pétition.
Des milliards d'influenceurs de renom
ont déjà rejoint ma cause.
(Cris indistincts)
Allez-y, mobilisez vous.
Merci à tous ceux qui me soutiennent sur
Ukip (Utip mal prononcé)
et une pensée émue à Jean-Paul et Ginette
qui sont malheureusement
encore de ce monde.
(Musique mexicaine joyeuse)